the golden age of anime not only when
anime started becoming a household term
worldwide
but when gem after gems started to be
produced
from shonen like fist of the north star
to psychological and mature shows like
neon genesis evangelion
to stylish cult classics like cowboy
bebop
no one can forget the omaywamo shinderu
the sea
space cowboy and shinji doing dastardly
deeds around his comatose friend
though i'm sure we would all actually
love to forget the last one
when was the golden age how did it come
to fruition
why was it golden well
many of the achievements of the
so-called golden age involve significant
breakthroughs of anime
into the western market more
specifically america
but this isn't because of some american
superiority complex of mine
it's simply that at the time america was
the gateway
and was spearheading much of modern
entertainment as it still does
but it meant that spreading anime to
america meant spreading anime to the
world
and while i could of course discuss the
roots of anime and its first steps in
america through 1963's astro boy or 1968
speed racer
in reality it's difficult to even call
this era anime
let alone a golden age because of
american redubs and heavy censorship
from television
networks these shows were adapted
completely
to a non-japanese audience most american
audiences at the time didn't even
realize that what they were watching was
originally japanese plus it wasn't
really a hit with networks
astro boy could only air 106 out of 124
episodes they planned
and the show was taken off the airways
after just one year
it's safe to say that the anime scene
had yet to flourish
and so we fast forward to the 80s the
beginning of an era that was marked with
one major landmark for us otaku and what
kickstarted the golden age
the hs
alongside an interest in anime in
general which had already made waves in
japan
many american companies rose to the
occasion of adapting anime for western
markets through vhs
because all they had to do was redub it
and
and that's about it it was cheap and
pretty damn easy
we saw a massive proliferation of
domestic licensers producing anime at
this time
animego and streamline in 1988 central
park media in 1990
and manga entertainment in 1991
which didn't actually make manga despite
the rather misleading name
and with these companies some of the
most famous titles to this day were
brought to western audiences
captain tsubasa which established the
sports anime formula in the early 80s
and set the standard for what has now
evolved into
basketball with super powers or devolved
into
whatever keijo is a series that i'm sure
makes our ancestors proud of how far
we've come as a species
streamline adapted akira into vhs a
movie which was surprisingly a huge
financial disappointment back in japan
despite having a huge film budget and
state of the art animation at the time
hell it's still beautiful to this day
it's better than seven deadly sins
akira was one of the most extreme cases
of international attention popularizing
anime
skyrocketing it to the famous heights it
now rests upon everywhere
in supreme collabs and art books
studio ghibli's first film nasikiya of
the valley of the wind
dropped in 84. central park media
released grave of the fireflies a
tearjerker and historical drama
manga entertainment adapted fist of the
north star and ghost in the shell
all of the biggest titles we know to
this day were making their debut through
vhs
however it wasn't all rainbows and
sunshine
quite yet after all when america
colonizes things
it's usually not all that great and that
feeling was starting to set in
companies like streamline only release
dubbed versions with
no extra subtitles at all and alongside
their rather
interpretive voiceovers much of the
original value was actually lost in
translation though some companies went
for more literal translations
certain jokes or references to famous
japanese historical figures
simply didn't work in english and a few
companies
even went so far as to make dub titles
to avoid this
where the subtitles aren't of the
original japanese script even
but of the dubbed version so not only
were they interpretive translations
but the subtitles couldn't even serve as
closed captions
because they had no captions for sound
effects or background music either
it's safe to say that uh dub titles did
not go down well in history books
in the mid-80s as mainstream anime made
huge strides
another industry knew that they had to
step up to the plate
and thus in 1984 the first ever hentai
lolita anime and the released soon after
cream lemon rose to the occasion i
i don't think i ever want to see the
words lolita and cream in the same
sentence
ever again man and yes this is still
relevant to america ruining the image of
anime in their country because big
companies like central park media
decided that
the best adult titles to adapt were ones
like urotsukudoji
the hentai that kicked off the long
lasting western misconception that all
anime was
just tentacle porn ad vision's release
of neon genesis evangelion with a
built-in jiggle counter
which they did in fact trademark because
i guess it was just such a
groundbreaking idea was also rather
detrimental to the show's
rather mature themes and philosophical
introspection
but i gotta give him credit it's it's
still pretty funny
one of the biggest companies manga
entertainment also confused us
ignorant americans because well they
didn't make
manga for people getting introduced into
the medium which
may be difficult already to traverse
this was just icing on the cake
really but pressure makes diamonds
and looking past all of these different
forms of censorship or misleading
marketing
at the end of the day anime was starting
to take its hold on the world
through new accessibility and amazing
films like akira
and despite the economic crash in japan
in 1991
anime's grip on the world was already
too strong for a mere recession to stop
its impending takeover
[Music]
notably studio ghibli continued to get
stronger and stronger through this
period
releasing big hits like kiki's delivery
service and their very
underrated and not very well known at
all film my neighbor totoro
toe also released sailor moon in 92
kickstarting a generation obsessed with
not just magical girls but
alongside the slightly older ghost in
the shell female characters being
prominent and powerful leads in
animation
ganax's release of neon genesis as i
mentioned earlier
similarly established two of the most
famous female anime archetypes
the tsundere and moe tropes that still
rarely change to this day
on top of this giant robots and
integration of religious symbols made
waves in the anime community
in fresh and new ways and as more
diverse animes started to be released
many otaku's at the time knew that
america's way of adapting couldn't
remain
that it had to meet those high standards
and thus
we began a great wave of fan subs
individuals or small collectives of fans
started subbing anime of their own
accord
which was the origins of the great
subverse dub war
i was personally raised with dubbed
anime dragon ball z and naruto on tv
were
my bread and butter i didn't watch a
subbed anime until i was at least like
10 years old
and so even though subs are important to
mention at the time
they were really only made for die hard
fans
even companies caught onto this and they
did start making subtitle versions of
movies
however they made less copies for higher
prices
because they knew that the demand from
the smaller subtitle chasing otaku
audiences would be willing to pay the
extra money for
the quality and because in america
dubb simply sold more from a sales
standpoint
and thus during the golden age of anime
dub ruled the world
more so what is important about fan subs
is that anime was getting around
a new type of japanese animation that
was frankly
taking over even more companies started
hopping on the train in the early 90s
most of which you will all recognize as
modern day monoliths
viz media with ronma one half four kids
with pokemon
bandai with cowboy bebop and funimation
with dragon ball
even disney hopped on the train striking
a deal with studio ghibli and releasing
their movies in america
starting with kiki's delivery service
and
of course with more attention comes more
and better anime
and the most notable we have to mention
has to be dragon ball
and dragon ball z
the integration of anime onto actual
television transitioning from vhs to tv
was
huge and marked the climax of the golden
age of anime
first released in japan in 1986 dragon
ball was
already huge in japan as the first big
shown in anime
or at least shonen in the way we refer
to it nowadays
and despite taking an entire decade to
be aired in america in 96
it likewise took american television by
storm
the most popular cartoon on cartoon
network for six months straight in 98
dragon ball z was huge and for good
reason
even as a kid growing up in the 2000s
dragon ball z was the first anime that i
ever watched and it certainly had a huge
impact on me as a kid
maybe even a decade after it was first
aired by the time i hopped on the train
and alongside fist of the north star the
trope of muscular dudes duking it out
and
saving the world soon began trailblazing
a path for
just about every kind of anime genre you
could imagine pokemon exploded onto the
scene in 98
expanding its reach on younger audiences
into games and toys
and all kinds of merchandise on a level
that has really
never been replicated since princess
mononoke released in 1999 by the
already established king of classic
anime studio ghibli
was the most expensive anime movie made
up to that point
genres were expanding too giving rise to
the dark and psychological
serial experiments lane and the
political epic legend of the galactic
heroes
which i highly recommend of course anime
was improving in just about
every way financially and in diversity
of quality
and to wrap off the decade in 1999
bandai just managed to creep in with
cowboy bebop
fighting for the spot of magnum opus of
the decade in terms of cult's following
and
long-lasting cultural effect in america
with a dub that
is renowned to be just as good if not
better than the subs version
something that can't be said for many
anime it signified that america was
finally getting their act together with
adapting anime properly
the iconic opening and soundtrack
stylish animation
and clash of western themes and ideas
meeting japanese animation
it all worked together perfectly
and what distinguishes this era isn't
just that it gave rise to mainstream
anime across the world
but the permanence of the new anime as
well
dragon ball z is a household name to
this day
as is just about every studio ghibli
film out there
inspiration of shows like fist of the
north star in jojo's bizarre adventure
and the onset of anime inspired cartoons
like avatar the last airbender
are just a handful of the numerous
inspirations
the golden age was something to behold
and it still
is it is something that will never be
forgotten
among us anime watchers and that is
its legacy now if you've made it this
far i didn't want to put it at the
beginning of the video
and detract from the main ideas but
thank you for 10 000 subscribers
it it really means a lot and i hope that
we can continue to grow together and
keep getting better
my next video will kick off a new series
that i'm starting called bedtime binge
which i'll give a little spoiler of here
but look forward to it definitely
acc only up and also
thanks for watching till the end of the
video as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga
and character analyses
you